[موسيقى]
يمكنني الجلوس هنا على جهاز الكمبيوتر المحمول الخاص بي
الآن ويمكنني الاتصال بأي حالة في أي
بلد
يمكننا الوصول إليه فعليًا في
غرف العمليات هذه لمساعدة هؤلاء الجراحين في مساعدة
هؤلاء المرضى في الحصول على الرعاية التي
ربما لم يتمكنوا من الوصول إليها  إلى [موسيقى] في
الماضي ،
انتقلنا من إجراء 50 حالة شهريًا إلى
أكثر من 800
900 حالة شهريًا واستمرار
التوسع كما تعلم ، لقد قمنا بإجراء
أكثر من 10000 حالة حتى الآن يحتاج كل مريض
في أي مكان في العالم إلى
الوصول إلى  يهتمون باحتياجهم إلى
جراحين يحبون العمل في فرق ،
وقد فعلنا ذلك غالبًا
منذ بداية الوقت ، فلنتعلم
معًا ، فلنشارك أفضل الممارسات
،
فلنجمع كل خبرات التعلم هذه
التي يمكن أن تفيد العديد من الجراحين الآخرين في
جميع أنحاء العالم
[الموسيقى] على ما
أعتقد  إذا نظرنا إلى التغييرات
وما سيبدو عليه مستقبل الجراحة
بالتأكيد ، فهناك عدد من
الموضوعات الرئيسية في الاتصال
الواقع المعزز الطباعة ثلاثية الأبعاد والتغييرات الأخرى
التي رأيناها بالفعل
ونستفيد منها  g من
تخيل غرف العمليات الذكية
وغرف العمليات الرقمية في
جميع أنحاء العالم المتصلة بالبيانات
المدفوعة بشكل
تعاوني ، تخيل أنه يمكننا إنشاء
شبكة اتصال بغرف العمليات في
جميع أنحاء العالم لأنه فقط
معًا ومع عنصر
اتصال قوي يمكننا حقًا
تحويل عملية التشغيل  مساحة للمستقبل